every year millions of people buy fifa
to play a game mode called
ultimate team and every year people
spend thousands of dollars
for the small chance of winning a rare
player card that could help them compete
in that game mode
but now people are accusing ea employees
of selling those same rare player cards
on a black
market and allegedly this has been
happening
for years it's all being referred to as
ea gate
you know how this works by now scroll
down and hit that subscribe button if
you haven't already and
while you're at it hit that notification
bell so you never miss
new content ever again alright
ea is back in the news because its
billion dollar fifa franchise continues
to be a broken and controversial
mess this time people on social media
are accusing ea
employees of selling extremely rare
player packs for its ultimate team game
mode
on a secretive black market completely
cutting out
millions of other players in the process
now at this point you're probably asking
yourself what are player packs what the
[ __ ] is ultimate team game mode
and why is all of this a big deal so
let me explain back in 2009 ea
introduced
ultimate team mode to fifa think of it
as a souped-up online version of the
franchise mode you're used to seeing in
sports games
you draft a team of players and then
take that team through
a season at the end of which hopefully
you're lifting some
stupid trophy since its introduction to
fifa all of ea's other
sports franchises like nhl and madden
have implemented this system
and all three titles have an esports
scene built around it
this is the biggest one uh this is what
everyone wants to see
this is where everyone's gonna be
looking at who is the kind of greatest
fifa player
at the current moment these are the two
best
xbox players in recent times the two big
things that separate ultimate team from
franchise mode is the fact that you
compete against other people online
and that in order to stand a chance of
winning you should probably buy these
things called player packs
what most people do is spend real money
on fifa's fake currency which you
then spend on player packs and these
packs give you a small chance to win
an incredibly rare player that could
then give you a huge advantage on the
field
you could technically grind your way
through thousands of hours of games to
get those same players but
ain't nobody got time for that now there
is a tier system with these player packs
and at the very rare end you have things
called
icon moments and team of the year packs
which
include the very best players who are
worth the most
money to put all of this into context
this player pack
icon moment ultimate team mode system
is extremely popular people spend
thousands of dollars a year
constantly buying and compulsively
opening these player packs
all of which makes ea billions of
dollars
so imagine spending all that time and
money for a chance to snag a player that
could help you win more
games just to find out that an ea
employee is allegedly selling them in
secret
to players in the know you'd be pretty
[ __ ] pissed
as were the hundreds of people talking
about this on twitter
there were multiple people showing
screenshots of what they
said is an ea employee telling people
how the process
worked as well as the prices for icon
moments and team of the year packs
and it's important to clarify that these
are just allegations for the moment
ea put out a statement which we'll get
to in a second but there's no definitive
proof yet that this was an ea employee
that being said
people tweeted out video footage of the
rare players being transferred to their
accounts
as evidence that this was happening can
i buy a prime icon moment from you
send 1 700 euros and i will payment sent
check your account so i've just logged
on to my account
and there it is crespo cheers eo i
appreciate it guys first owner
we love to see it one of the people
talking about this early on
and sharing all of the information that
he had was fifa youtuber nick
2018 he threw out a bunch of different
theories including one where rogue ea
employees were actually scamming the
company themselves
here he is talking about it on his
channel apparently
it's basically these ea employees that
are scamming ea pretending like
people's accounts are professional
player accounts they take the 1700 euros
or the thousand dollars or the three
thousand dollars
and then they basically get all the
information and get an ea bot
to send these players into people's
accounts so what he's saying there is
that he thinks
ea employees are going to ea and are
saying
hey we're talking to a big time content
creator or pro player
can we send them over a bunch of rare
cards and if nick's theory is true
those ea employees are lying because
what they're doing
is taking those rare cards and selling
them to joeshmo
on twitter this caused such a stir on
social media that the typically
oblivious ea took notice eventually
releasing a statement that said they
were looking into the situation
quote we are aware of the allegations
currently circulating within our
community related to fifa 21
ultimate team items a thorough
investigation is underway and if we
identify improper conduct we will take
swift
action we want to be clear this type of
behavior is unacceptable
and we in no way condone what is alleged
to have happened here
we understand how this creates concern
about unfair balance in the game and
competition
we will update the community as we get
more clarity on the situation
end quote for what it's worth i reached
out to ea for comment and
never heard back now let me emphasize
something here
you can't just buy these player packs
with real
money that's a huge no-no that ea is
very clear about
since it would essentially invalidate
the currency system ea has created
and implement an even more egregious
pay-to-win system
this problem threatens the very
foundation of one of ea's cash cabs
like if this black market selling is
actually happening
there goes the competitive integrity of
fifa's most competitive game mode
and honestly why would anyone want to go
back to using ea's
already broken system i get it man
people found a loophole in a system that
allows them to remove the element of
chance and guarantees them what they
want
i can't blame them for doing it even if
it's wrong and let's not get it twisted
fifa's ultimate team mode is a pay to
win system disguised as a loot box
mechanic
and that loot box mechanic funnily
enough has landed ea
in hot legal water over the last few
years similar to the gambling
accusations that have been leveled at
case openings in cs go
which if you're a fan of counter-strike
you'll know all about
ea and fifa's player packs have faced
their own gambling reckoning
more specifically the company is
currently facing three class
action lawsuits which all allege that
the game's player pack system
is nothing more than a loot box gambling
mechanic
and because fifa's loot boxes are more
than just cosmetic skins like in cs go
because they fundamentally change your
odds of winning
all three lawsuits allege that they keep
the player base engaged for longer
while encouraging addictive and
potentially negative gambling habits a
netherlands district court even sided
against ea
stating that the company's loot box
mechanics violated the country's
gambling and betting act
the court then stated that if ea didn't
remove its loot boxes from its games
within an
8-week window they would be fined 10
million
euros ea ignored this ruling by the way
what's 10 mil to a 37 billion dollar
company
we reported on this entire situation
back in january
they're battling three class action
lawsuits in court
at the heart of the complaints in the
lawsuits are loot boxes
in a concept called dynamic difficulty
adjustment
here's where i'm at with all of this if
ea
employees were actually selling ultra
rare cards on a black market system that
they themselves created
that's [ __ ] up and should be dealt
with accordingly but
at the same time i see this as an
opportunity to take a look at
ultimate team and for ea to hopefully
make changes for the better
like it's absolutely insane to me that
in order to enjoy the main game mode the
reason why
most people play fifa you potentially
have to drop
hundreds of dollars extra i wonder if
there's a world where ultimate team
exists but it didn't feel so predatory
to the same people who support it year
after year look i get it the changes
that i'm talking about means that
ea probably makes less money which will
never happen
they don't give a [ __ ] about your
spending habits as long as it's all
above
board and legal and when the opposite
happens as we've seen
here when things get a little murky
legally and the ultimate golden goose is
threatened ea is quick to right the ship
and figure out what
happened hopefully when they do so will
we
when things get a little murky legally
when the ultimate golden team [ __ ]
i can't speak african words today
quote quote quote quote quote
quote quote quote quote quote quote
quote no quote quote that should work
for you colton
moo